I'm planning a 10-day trip to Ireland of
Wow, it is September. So right off the bat, I'm pretty sure you have to take me with you.
That's the, what do you mean? That's this question is going to take me with.
Just kidding. I was contemplating adding extra days before and after
to extend my trip. I hesitate because I have no idea.
Other than the fact that I still feel the lump in my breast
progression or not progression on my cancer. I don't want to be foolish and miss too many
days of my detox and rife. Because I would say and we've mentioned before that, you know,
taking the rife overseas maybe, you know, an issue going through customs and stuff.
I probably wouldn't do that. And I don't think this person is planning to bring in their
rife from their trip to Ireland. And they're concerned that 10 days or 14 days or
whatever it's going to be might be a long time without it. I'm two years post-diagnosis
and I haven't had a scan or since my MRI in August of last year.
Another MRI is, oh, because of the GAD. GAD is short for Gantelidium, which is a die.
I used some contrast in the MRI this person gets.
I thought PET scan might be most useful. I could, it could tell me if the lump is still cancer
or has become from a product by product. It also would tell me if there's any metastasis
after two years. I spoke with my colleges about this after having not seen her for the
years, having refused the medication at my first appointment with her.
And she said PET scan was notably unreliable, picking up active disease of the breast tissue.
Oh, gosh, I am totally discrepancy because if you don't have, you know,
a highly metabolic, if it's become fibronic, it's not going to be highly metabolic.
I don't understand what she's saying about that. That makes absolutely zero sense to me.
So a PET scan will light up the term for it when you have highly metabolic tissue.
So that's why it'll pick up metastasis. And it always picks up the primary cancer.
The primary cancer is growing. So if there is no growth, it's a lot of dead tissue,
a lot of the chronic cells, if I brought a tissue as this person mentioned,
it's not going to light up on test kit. That would be a, that would be a good test to do.
But she also said insurance will cover it unless I'm stage three or more.
I will stage one B at diagnosis, or I have symptoms of metastasis, possibly, which I don't.
She's pushing me for a mammogram and ultrasound plus biopsy.
Not interested in compressing the tumor with a mammogram.
Not convinced that the ultrasound radiation is harmless.
And I don't want to puncture the tumor again. I would totally agree.
The other thing about, I mean, I think that the ultrasound would be the least invasive,
because the PET scan is not not invasive, still using radiation.
And I think it's much more invasive than ultrasound.
And so I'd be more up to say ultrasound. The negative is, is the ultrasound is not going to differentiate
whether it's my erotic tissue or it's active cancer.
It's just going to show a mass. So that's the negative.
Not interested. I'm just stuck. Never know what's going on.
Or am I just stuck? What's the wisest decision?
Well, I know you, I know you're feeling great.
Personally, I'd say is go on the trip. Don't even worry about test to do.
If you want to get some objective testing, you could run tumor markers.
If, if, be say that, if your answer is, I've done two markers, they don't show up.
Well, then I would just go on the trip. I just go enjoy yourself.
Are you trying to get better in the first place? So you could do this kind of stuff.
So go enjoy yourself. That can be the best thing.
You don't remember so much of healing is between our ears.
So going in a joy life, you're not neglecting what you ought to do.
You are doing what you ought to do. You are doing what you ought to do 50 weeks of the year
so that you could go do this and have this be something you ought to do also.
So have no guilt, go enjoy yourself and just have a fantastic time.
I think that will be so good for you.